- [Instructor] A strong acid is an acid
that ionizes 100% in solution.
For example, hydrochloric
acid, HCl, as a strong acid
it donates a proton to water, H2O,
to form the hydronium ion, H3O plus,
and the conjugate base to HCl
which is the chloride anion, Cl minus.
In reality, this reaction
reaches an equilibrium.
However, the equilibrium
lies so far to the right
and favors the product so
much that we don't draw
an equilibrium arrow,
we simply draw an arrow
going to the right,
indicating the reaction
essentially goes to completion.
And if the reaction
essentially goes to completion,
we can say that hydrochloric
acid ionizes 100%
and forms hydronium ions
and chloride anions.
So essentially there is no more HCl left,
it's all turned into
H3O plus and Cl minus.
It's also acceptable to
completely leave water
out of the equation and to
show hydrochloric acid, HCl,
turning into H plus and Cl minus.
Once again, since HCl is a strong acid,
there's only an arrow going to the right
indicating HCl ionizes 100%.
And since there's only one
water molecule difference
between H plus and H3O
plus, H plus and H3O plus
are used interchangeably.
Hydrochloric acid is an example
of a monoprotic strong acid.
Monoprotic means, hydrochloric
acid has one proton
that it can donate in solution.
Other examples of monoprotic
strong acids include
hydrobromic acid, HBr,
hydroiodic acid, HI,
nitric acid, HNO3, and
perchloric acid, HClO4.
Sulfuric acid is H2SO4
and it's a strong acid,
but it's a diprotic acid,
meaning it has two protons
that it can donate, however,
only the first ionization
for sulfuric acid is strong.
Let's calculate the pH of
a strong acid solution.
In this case, we're gonna
do a 0.040M solution
of nitric acid.
Nitric acid is HNO3, and
nitric acid reacts with water
to form hydronium, H3O plus,
and nitrate, NO3 minus,
which is the conjugate base 2HNO3.
Because nitric acid is a strong acid,
we assume the reaction goes to completion.
Therefore, if the initial
concentration of nitric acid
is 0.040M, looking at our mole ratios
in the balanced equation,
there's a one in front
of nitric acid and there's also
a one in front of hydronium
and a one in front of nitrate.
Therefore, if the reaction
goes to completion,
the concentration of
hydronium would also be 0.040M
and the same with the nitrate anion,
that would also have a
concentration of 0.040M.
Since our goal is to calculate
the pH of this solution,
we know that the equation
for pH is pH is equal
to the negative log of the
concentration of hydronium ions.
Therefore, we just need to
plug in the concentration
of hydronium ions into our equation.
This gives us the pH is equal
to the negative log of 0.040,
which is equal to 1.40.
So even though this is
a pretty dilute solution
of nitric acid, because
nitric acid is a strong acid,
the pH is pretty low.
Also note since we have
two significant figures
for the concentration of hydronium ions,
we need two decimal places
for our final answer.
Let's do another problem
with a strong acid solution.
Let's say we have 100 ml
of an aqueous solution
of hydroiodic acid and
the pH of the solution
is equal to 1.50.
And our goal is to find the mass of HI
that's present in solution.
Hydroiodic acid reacts with
water to form the hydronium ion
and the iodide anion.
And the mole ratio of HI
to H3O plus is one-to-one.
So if we can find the
concentration of hydronium ion
and solution, that should also be
the initial concentration
of hydroiodic acid.
And once we find
the initial concentration
of hydroiodic acid,
we can find the mass of HI that's present.
Since we are given the pH in the problem,
we can plug that directly
into our equation,
which gives us 1.50 is
equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions.
To solve for the concentration
of hydronium ions,
we can first move the negative
sign to the left side,
which gives us negative
1.50 is equal to the log
of the concentration of hydronium ions.
And to get rid of the log,
we can take 10 to both sides.
So the concentration of hydronium ions
is equal to 10 to the negative 1.50,
which is equal to 0.032.
So the concentration of
hydronium ions is 0.032M.
And because the mole ratio
of hydronium ion to HI
is one-to-one, the initial
concentration of HI
is also 0.032M.
Now that we know the
initial concentration of HI,
we're ready to find
the mass of HI present.
Molarity is moles per liter,
so let's go ahead and rewrite this
as 0.032 moles per liter.
The volume of the solution
is 100 milliliters,
which is equal to 0.100 liters.
So if we multiply moles
per liter by the volume,
which is 0.100 liters, liters
will cancel and give us moles.
So this is equal to
0.0032 moles of HI.
Since our goal is to find
the mass of HI present,
the final step is to
multiply the moles of HI
by the molar mass which is
128 grams per one mole of HI.
So most of HI would cancel out
and this gives us 0.41 grams
as our final answer.